I was just telling you I've spent some
time out in Detroit uh recently and uh
man I really wish you were doing in
Detroit hanging out with uh we shot with
Sada baby out there uh on the east side
we were with payroll Giovanni on the
west side we were with uh we were with
uh I swear Vezzo he was shooting his
movie
so we just stayed out there for a week
and just shot a bunch of stuff for above
all and it was it was fun man I enjoyed
it a lot okay I don't know what to
expect because you hear like you know
you gotta come [ __ ] with us next time
when you come to the demon what part of
Detroit are you from I'm from Seven Mile
Evergreen okay is that the east side or
west side just the West Side okay deep
deep website deep West Side I know like
there's like a bit of a Vibe change from
the west side east yeah what do you
think the volume well from what I would
say that like the west side seems a
little from what everyone has told me is
a little bit more of the flashier
Hustler yeah that's where the East
side's a little more like you know
grimy maybe you know what I'm saying
like so I don't know I I really uh the
food was cool I told you there's a
[ __ ] Coney Island on every corner did
you go to starters I don't think I did
okay I just know we was just pulling up
to Coney Islands
that was like everybody would go to
their Hood they'd be like we got to take
you to our Coney yeah because that's
that's that's that's a real big thing in
Detroit uh you know what county did you
go to right because you know you know
you asked me what's my favorite cone is
Lions Coney Island on Seven Mile okay
and it's because we got this omelet
called The Seven Mile omlet oh and
basically they put everything in the
whole store in it inside the Almond yeah
hash browns all type of music sounds
like a movie
that sounds like [ __ ] diarrhea though
that sounds like a [ __ ] problem for
the [ __ ] toilet oh man and then we
were super cliche yeah we were driving
through Nikki D's uh drive-through okay
it was two o'clock in the morning no it
was this was like 1pm because we had to
shoot at like two and they were like go
to Nikki D's it's right over here and
then we this was the first time we'd
been on Eight Mile Road right so I'm
like fresh and this is like our first
day in town yeah so did you did you
notice the potholes oh yeah okay okay
cool so I'm just [ __ ] blaring Eminem
in the [ __ ] drive through just being
like the most stereotypical
white dude who's on vacation
I was doing it to be be funny but but
then we actually drove to the trailer
park
the Eight Mile trailer park and that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up I was like this is
crazy
like this [ __ ] is depressing
yeah about a game they're like yeah it
was like some toothless lady smoking
she's on the corner I'm like hey which
one was Eminem she's like you see that
empty lot right there was right there
they tore it down wow I was like [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up over there man
man that's what it's got the movie here
yes where they shot the movie at man
they take you on Seven Mile and Dresden
I don't know we're everywhere that's
another house we live in Detroit did it
no no I just drove I just drove by we
just Googled uh Eminem trailer park and
just went there you know many people
come from like all around the world just
to see eight mile I'm sure from overseas
I'm sure I'm sure and it's probably not
the safest place to just be hanging out
at right
what do you think I would say based on
my experience all the places we were at
were not too far from Eight Mile and we
were in some pretty hairy areas yeah
like yeah probably like y'all's on Seven
Mile and
but uh but yeah I would say you know
probably not the the smartest thing I
did do the uh
mom's spaghetti restaurant was [ __ ]
just terrible chocolate for the mom's
spaghetti it wasn't good man I I wanted
to like it you Italian didn't you nah
okay I'm just I'm German and Irish I
can't tell what you is because you ain't
got much the German and Irish bro German
Irish boring white okay
I feel like if you're Italian there's
like some sort of like no I'm not white
I'm Italian what what German and Irish
is like that's like crazy you're a crazy
[ __ ] that's just white as [ __ ]
that's like it's about as boring of
caucet I mean the only thing I could say
other is like being English okay yeah